The film touches on so many
different themes, one that really stood
out to me was the kind of immense inner
strength that women have - is that quite
important to you when you're taking on a
role, to portray that? I mean I'm always
going to be more attracted to women who
have some kind of conflict to play and
something that's not just a
two-dimensional character so yeah that's
always - the draw is to play a character
with depth and and a sense of meaning
and not just to sort of reactionary role
to a male co-star you know. But I think
strength is not necessarily the word
that I look for, I look for complexity
and because you know it's that funny
thing that no one ever describes a male
character is like 'wow that's a really
strong character', it's sort of, and I feel
like the same should go for female roles
as well we should just accept people as
being complicated and flawed and you
know everything that people, that women
are, you know. So one of the most tense
and emotional moments in the film is the
bathtub scene. I was writhing in my seat,
because it was so stressful.
Obviously labour is such a difficult
thing and with the added circumstances it
must have been quite a stressful
headspace to get in to. Yeah I mean I think it
was quite a stressful headspace, I mean we
shot it over five days that, from start
to finish, from the moment the water
breaks till the moment that
had you squirming, in the bathtub. I feel like
everyone on set was like crossing their
legs... Yes! But it was an exhausting sequence I
will say that, but ultimately I knew
that it was gonna pack a
punch, I think you're a little excited by
doing those sequences because you know
what it'll mean to an audience. Yeah. So
you and John I've obviously worked
together quite a few times and you're
married... Well not really worked together....A few - the voiceovers. So with this film the dialogue
was quite different as in, there wasn't very much of it, did you find that you
learnt anything about each other while
you were working together because there was
less talking going on? I mean the only
thing I can think of is that in some
ways you are a slightly different person
when you're at work and and I think that
that was the thing we were a bit nervous
about is whether we'd be able to embrace
that about the person you know that this
is not domestic life when you're on set.
And I think we, the only things that
surprised us was sort of just how well
we collaborated together and I think
everything else when it came to his
ability and his talent as a director and
as a filmmaker and a visionary person
was something I've always known about
him and I was just more excited for
people to find that out too. Your career
has gone from strength to strength which
obviously means a lot of travelling, a lot
of late nights, a lot of early
mornings. Have you got any wellness hacks
that you kind of picked up along the
road that you want to share with our
followers? I would say if you feel
yourself coming down with a cold which
I'm like the worst person to nominate
this because I sound horrible today, tail
end of laryngitis, but but I do find oil
of oregano... Oh... Oil of oregano. Oh I sound, I'm so used to hearing the American version. Oil
of oregano. I'll never understand why they say it like that. I know when I ask
for oregano out there they're like
what? It's like oregano... But you
actually sort of just throw a few drops
down there.
it's disgusting, oh wow, you burn your throat but
I do tend to find it shortens the cold.
Awesome. And are there any beauty
products that you swear by that our
followers should know about? Anything
you've used forever and ever? Well I
absolutely love Sisely products I think
they are beautiful. I love them. And Clé de Peau do the most fantastic little
foundation sticks. I love them. Concealer
sticks I should say. I've got a bit
of a quickfire round. Go on then.
Just either/or. So mascara or
lipstick? *Gasp* Mascara.
Fish or chips? Oh, um chips. Beach holiday or
a city break? Hmm I quite like a city break
now.
Madonna or Britney? Oh. Britney. Full glam or
all-natural? All-natural. And horror films
or rom-coms? Rom-coms.